einfache mit grad wie heute mal ganz
ohne tagwache und auch nicht in der
kaserne einen schönen guten abend von
einem der vielen christkindlmärkte hier
in österreich in dem fall einen
besonders schönen über den dächern der
stadt wien
das ist ein ganz spezieller gruß an alle
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter und
alle soldatinnen und soldaten des
österreichischen heeres inclusive einen
kleinen dank von mir persönlich für eine
großartige zusammenarbeit bisher weit
über eine million menschen haben bis
jetzt gesehen online was das bundesheer
in österreich so drauf hat
das ist ihr und euer verdienst dafür ein
großes dankeschön ich freu mich schon
auf das was alles noch kommen mag
und es ist hier ein ganz spezieller
weihnachtsgruß an sie alle an euch alle
an die am 24
dezember oder auch über das neue jahr
dienst machen und ganz speziell an die
fast 1000 die weit entfernt von der
heimat im ausland ihren dienst versehen
an euch ganz ganz herzlich vor
weihnachten ein friedliches neues jahr
und ein ganz spezieller cruz von den
herren der garde film ab
mit diesen größen von der garde er sagt
auch ich danke für eine tolle
zusammenarbeit bisher die freue mich auf
ein tolles neues gemeinsames jahr 2018
münchen viel soldatenglück wer war denn
das wäre schade gewesen was nicht
getroffen aber vor allem euch und ihnen
ein friedliches weihnachten und einen
guten rutsch ist naja als sie wert